Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sam from New York City
on what is not an auspicious start here. Sam from
New York City, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Can you hear me?
I'll try to help turn things around.
Speaker 1: Yeah, please, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: All right. I'll try my best. One
question that I've grappled with really since
I guess, you know, Trump came down
the escalator. You know, that moment
is you know, I know you don't identify that you're
not a registered Democrat, correct? That's right.
You tend to align with them. I am a registered
Democrat, but also like you have my issues with
the party. One thing I try to ask myself is what
would it take for me to vote for a Republican even
when I consider how seem. Decision must be to vote
for Donald Trump, I think I cannot imagine how
anyone would logically come to that conclusion.
One thing I try to ask myself is, all right,
well, what would Democrats do that would make
me not support a Democrat? Is there a line being
I'm not being super clear, but I guess. Should
we be more understanding of potential reasons
Republicans voted for Trump when his
Democrats are incredibly unwilling
to consider voting Republican?
Speaker 1: Well, you've got to
talk to the Democrats that you're referring to
and see what their answer would be like. For me,
it's really clear if you give me a race where
the Republican is the better option than the
Democrat based on policy and based on all of the
things that we look at, like in other words, if in
the last election Joe Biden was the Republican and
Trump was the Democrat, I would have voted for the
Republican, Joe Biden, because I thought Joe Biden
was the better option. What you're I think getting
to is people who are blindly voting for party
without really looking at the candidates. Right.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I guess it's
also a moral question. Let's say
the Republican and Democrat are both sort
of generic middle-of-the-road Republicans,
Democrats in terms of policy, but the Democrat is
incredibly compromised or, you know, some personal
behavior or whatever else. Sure. Yeah, I
Speaker 1: mean, that's one consideration.
The other consideration could be you might
have a very centrist Democrat and a very
centrist Republican. And they are very similar
on policy. But you might say, well, overall,
the platform of the Democratic Party is closer to
my view than the platform of the Republican Party.
So even though I'm kind of indifferent on these
two candidates, I'll vote for the Democrat because
their party has the platform I prefer. This
is unfortunately, this is way more thought
than most people put into who they vote for.
Speaker 4: I mean, I hate to say it, but it's
sort of like I believe that just take
health care policy by the Democrats. So
many thousands of can has the potential
to save thousands of American lives, even
if some Democrat. It's obviously hypothetical,
went out and killed someone and they killed one
person. But I think electing them would pass
health care policy that would save thousands
of lives. And you can sort of make a calculation,
that utilitarian calculation certified and then I.
No. Yeah, no, that makes sense.
Speaker 1: I mean, that's sort of like if you
have two candidates, one of whom is a rapist but
would likely pass Medicare for all, does it still
make sense to vote for the rapist? Because it's
going to be good for so many people? I mean, yet
you start to get into those types of questions and
it's a very personal thing for a lot of people.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, thank you
for your thoughtfulness on this.
Speaker 1: Appreciate the call. Thank
you very much. Very important topic.